رئيس الجمهورية الجزائري
عبدالمجيد تبون مكالمة هاتفية مع
لمدينة نيكولاي في جنوب
اوكرانيا. امين العام للنايتو
الجزائر لحين هناك توجه جزائري
جديد للتقارب مع الصين على
الالي ستة وخمسون وقتل ما يصل
الى مائتي مقاتل بما في ذلك
في المحافل الدولية. بعد اقل من
اسبوع على تولي منصبه القائد
تكثف عملياتها العسكرية وتستهدف
مصنعا لاصلاح الدبابات في صواريخ
الصعيد الخارجي. الصين وامريكا
بين شد وجذب. واشنطن تطلب وبكين
فكيف ستكون النهاية في الوقت
الذي تعود به اوروبا الى العصور
التدريب نتيجة عطل فني ونجاة
قائدها دون بقية التفاصيل. اجرى
التدريبي للقوات الجوية سقطت
طائرة مقاتلة باحدى مناطق
امتنانه لنظيره التركي خلال
اتصال هاتفي على جهوده في احباط
اسكندر بحسب وزارة الدفاع
الروسية. قام زيلنسكي الذي نادرا
واسرائيل وامريكا وان من بين
مخططات اسقاط حكومته السعي
صواريخ وقذائف متطورة الاوكراني
ينطر مواقع الانفصاليين الموالين
لايف العبري ان الرئيس
الاسرائيلي اسحاق اعرب عن
اننا نتوقع ان تكثف روسيا نشاطها
العدائي هذا الاسبوع. نحن نستعد
بعد. اعلنت وزارة الدفاع المصرية
انه في اطار تنفيذ النشاط
يانس تولتنبرج الاسلحة الحديثة
سترجح كفة كييف لاستعادة دومباص.
زيننسكي يتحدى روسيا قائلا لن
نتنازل عن الجنوب. من الواضح
القضاء على اكثر من مائة جندي
اوكراني. كما هزم لواء المشاة
هجوم ارهابي على الاراضي التركية
مشددا على ان التهديد لم ينتهي
المرتزقة الاجانب. بعد وصول
الامدادات العسكرية الغربية من
نحن جاهزون. لافروف واشنطن لن
تتمكن من حرمان موسكو من صوتها
الباكستانيين. ويقول ان الحكومة
الحالية تريد تحقيق مخططات الهند
للاعتراف باسرائيل وتحقيق اجندات
دول تعادي باكستان. ذكر مفزاك
ما يتنقل خارج العاصمة منذ بدء
الغزو الروسي بزيارته الاولى
لروسيا في مقاطعة باكثر من
اربعمائة قذيفة. القوات الروسية
العودة للعصر الحجري. اوروبا
تهرب من الغاز الروسي الى
جيش قادر على هزيمة روسيا. عمران
خان يظهر امام المحتجين
الاوكرانية دول اوروبا كلها
تواجه ذات المصير بالعودة الى
واستخدام عمليات الضم للضغط
الدبلوماسي والنفسي على تايوان.
الجاري. ولفتن بيرج الى ان الصين
سيشار اليها في العقيدة الجديدة
نظيره الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون
تطرقا فيها الى العلاقات
الثنائية بين البلدين. هل تحاول
فرنسا اذابة جليد التوترات مع
تعبيره. وزارة الدفاع الروسية
تعلن ان صواريخ عالية الدقة ضربت
الاحتباس الحراري زي اللي بيهرب
من حفرة ويقع في كما يقول
الجديد للجيش البريطاني باتريك
ساندرز يكشف عن الحاجة الى انشاء
تغزو بعض او كل جزر تايوان
البعيدة عن الجزيرة الاساسية.
المانيا اكثر الدول الاوروبية
على الغاز الروسي ويمثل الغاز
المصريون. المانيا اعلنت اجراءات
طارئة بينها العودة الى استخدام
والتطورات. كشف الامين العام
لحلف الناتو ينس تولتنبرج ان
تايوان. او قد الصين الحرب
الالكترونية لتحقيق الهدف نفسه.
كامل على مضيق تايوان ما يمنع
ادخال واخراج اي شيء. بينما يمكن
ويلجأ بدل ذلك الى الضربات
الجوية والصاروخية لتدمير البنية
قطارا فيه افراد في منطقة
دينيبرو بتروفستيك وانه تم
بالفحم الحجري لمواجهة انقطاع
غاز موسكو بسبب الازمة
وهذه بعض السيناريوهات التي يمكن
ان تنفذها بكين. يمكن للصين ان
التحتية العسكرية والمدنية
الرئيسة. ما سيؤدي الى شل دفاعات
تتدارك اوروبا نفسها تتجنب
مصيرها البائس الاحداث
الروسي خمسين بالمئة من
استهلاكها بعد المانيا اعلنت
الجديدة التي يعتزم الناتو
تبنيها في قمة مدريد اواخر الشهر
كما يمكن للصين ايضا ان تختار
عدم مهاجمة الجزيرة الرئيسية
روسيا ستعتبر تهديدا امنيا في
عقيدة الحلف الاستراتيجية
ويمكن ان تفرض الصين اغلاقا
جمركيا اي السيطرة فعال على
لجيش التحرير الشعبي الصيني ان
يمتنع عن تنفيذ غزو بري كامل.
الفحم فيما وصفته بانه خطوة
مريرة لكن لا غنى عنها وتعد
العصور الغابرة حال وصلت روسيا
قطع غازها عن القارة العجوز. فهل
الحكومة النمساوية انها ستعيد هي
الاخرى تشغيل محطة طاقة تعمل
امريكية سابقة بشأن قضية اعتبار
مضيق تايوان ممرا بحري دوليا
الحدود الجوية والبحرية لتايوان.
قد تختار بكين ايضا فرض حصار
الغربية جعلت الصينيين يترددون
بخصوص هذه الاسلحة. اما اليوم
للحلف لاول مرة وان صعودها يمثل
تحديا لمصالحنا وامننا وفق
فالصين تستعد لتزويد روسيا
بمعدات طائرات وامريكا تحذر من
اطلاق سراح الامريكيين المحتجزين
في الصين يعد اولوية شخصية له.
ما يصعد المخاوف من ان بكين
هجوما عسكريا على جزيرة تايوان
وللرئيس بايدن تكثر الطلبات
الامريكية للصينيين لكن من كثرت
طلبت من بكين مسيرة وصواريخ
دقيقة التوجيه لكن العقوبات
بحسب وكالة بلومبرج وماذا بعد
ايها الامريكان. تعرض الصين
تساوي ما او تخضع بشأن سيادتها.
نعم لا مزاح لدى اصحاب العيون
لروسيا وانها حليف عسكري ضخم في
حرب موسكو ضد اوكرانيا. من جانب
مسؤولون في ادارة بايدن عن قلقهم
من الرد الصيني على تصريحات
خرق العقوبات. فلماذا تطلب روسيا
الغنية بالاسلحة اسلحة صينية? هل
العلاقات الامريكية الصينية.
وروسيا. سابقا كانت موسكو قد
قوتها بشكل متزايد على الساحة
الدولية في ظل رئاسة شي جين بينغ
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جاك سوليفن ابلغ الصينيين ان
اخر تقول واشنطن بان مائتي
امريكي محتجزون تعسفيا لدى بكين
احذروا غضب التنين الصيني ايها
الامريكان. صحيفة جلوبال تايمز
الصينية تصف المشروع بالمسيء
والخطير وتحذر من تداعياته على
طلباته قلت قيمته هكذا يرد
الصينيون. قلقوا واشنطن. عبر
تريد ادخال الصين خط المواجهة ام
انها تريد ان للعالم ولاء الصين
مضادة حازمة مؤكدا ان بكين ليس
لديها مجال للمساومة او التنازل
يعود للظهور مجددا. سقوط طائرة
مقاتلة مصرية والجزائر تبني
الضيقة. ونبه المتحدث من ان
اقرار القانون قد يثير اجراءات
اوكرانيا باسلحة سترجح كفتها في
الحرب. فهل هذا صحيح? وعمران خان
قانون سياسة تايوان الفين واثنين
وعشرين. ودعا الى وقف مناقشته
واعتبر انه قد يتسبب باجراءات
مضادة من جانب بكين لانها لن
علاقاتها المتينة هو الهدف يا
ترى بينما يستمر الكر والفر بين
للمساومة او التنازل. هكذا
اعلنتها بكين لواشنطن. فهل من رد
مجهول. مرة اخرى يظهر زلنيسكي
خارج العاصمة كييف. الناتو يدعم
المتحدث باسم السفارة الصينية في
واشنطن. حذر من تمرير مشروع
الصين وامريكا؟ وما هي
سيناريوهات غزو بكين لتايوان؟
ولماذا تحتجز الصين ائتي شخص
امريكي. اوروبا تعود للعصور
قوات موسكو وكييف في الاراضي
الاوكرانية. الصين وامريكا.
القديمة بسبب غاز روسيا ودول
اوروبا المتطورة امام مستقبل
امريكي؟ الصين تكسر العقوبات
الغربية وتستعد لتزويد روسيا
القديمة.
بالاسلحة. ما كل هذه الجرأة؟
وكيف ستنتهي الحرب الباردة بين
اياكم ان تمسوا وحدة الصين
وسيادة اراضيها فليس لدينا مجال